freedom from one fight a man we
astronauts are bringing with them for
Mediaset
right did you get the ring yeah where
did you come from could it come from a
shuttle neither man robbed the shuttle
by offering a million dollars once in my
life I'm worth something I can't collect
[Music]
I don't know how I got here and I'm
gonna costume I've never seen before
nothing on earth could do it this does
I've developed a lot more than a back
Packer
I am to me
it's a Symbian and organism that thrives
by bonding with another you've got to
get that suit off I can't have some
things I take care of first
I'm invincible
by your friendly superhero milkman Lane
Luckie
what have I done what's this costume
doing stay away from me I'm not like you
[Music]
enjoy your stay
why is he
see youtubers it's Charlie amazing news
they're going to be making a venom movie
is going to be hardcore as an r-rated
hardcore so I'll explain what's going on
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
videos every week I'm even doing a
spider-man action figure giveaway going
on right now how appropriate the reason
everyone is freaking out is because
there is now a venom movie from Sony
that has confirmed for October 5th 2018
originally what happened is is the
Aquaman movie was going to come out then
so suni swapped their date in December
with Aquaman for this Sony also has the
animated spider-man Miles Morales movie
coming out in December against Aquaman
so there's a whole bunch of spider-man
happening at the end of 2018 so as of
right now they haven't said how this is
connected to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of spider-man because
the idea is that it's sort of like
they're rated our Deadpool movie so
think of what a rated our spider-man
movie might look like so that kind of
makes it harder to crossover with Tom
Holland so while you have to include
spider-man somehow I'm not expecting him
to outright just like pop up in the
Marvel Universe and start slaying a
bunch of people because I think the real
advantage here that Sony has is that it
could do the Deadpool thing where it's
connected to all the other spider-man
movies but they can do it in a
roundabout way so that they're not
completely shackled to the tone of the
spider-man film so Tom Holland is going
to be an amazing spider-man I'm so
excited about spider-man homecoming but
the thing is that's more of a high
school movie about growing up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like Peter
Parker's just trying to be a normal kid
while all this crazy Avengers stuff is
going on it's a lot more like a Disney
movie and Disney is committed to not
doing rated R movies so Sony who just
has a sharing arrangement can do all the
rated-r spider-man they want just as
long as it doesn't trample on their main
spider-man franchise so you have to
imagine that the spider-man group of
characters is just like a billion dollar
cash cow but that doesn't mean that they
all have to be the exact same type of
movie it's the same thing with x-men
they hit a home run with a rated R Logan
rated our Deadpool rated our x-force is
coming down the road that's like a rated
R version of an x-men film so why
wouldn't Sony try to do the same thing
with characters that
are rated are by their very nature venom
is a very hard our character in that is
where you put your carnage because the
great thing about venom is that you can
make him an antihero even the Eddie
Brock version of the character you might
be familiar with a couple different
versions I'll explain them in a second
but anytime spider-man's around venom is
the bad guy how do you make him the good
guy you bring in somebody even crazier
batshit crazy and that is carnage so
they haven't said what the story is
going to be but they have writers that
are working on it so the day could get
pushed it just depends on how soon they
find their actors to get into production
but this just confirms that they're
doing something so let me know what you
guys think of that you have to be going
crazy so the really cool fan Theory
that's out there right now is that
Sony's Life movie which stars Deadpool
himself is secretly a venom prequel
because they find an alien organism in
outer space on Mars bring it back to
earth and it's very much like the Venom
symbiote while I don't think the theory
is true the reason why is because people
spotted stock footage from spider-man 3
in the trailer for the life movie but
the thing is is that companies that make
trailers for movies reuse footage from
other movies all the time so it's just a
coincidence that there's a spider-man 3
shot in this movie that's coming out
really soon but I do love the idea that
Sony stealth made a venom prequel it had
deadpool guest star in it that would
take some crazy contract work between
Sony and Fox behind the scenes you've
probably seen at least one version of
the character from the TV series the
animated series even spider-man 3 we
don't have to talk about spider-man 3
that was actually a character that was
supposed to be the vulture the first
time around I'll link to spider-man
video where I explained the vulture it
was a cool story about how they swapped
a bunch of characters in for Sam Raimi a
third spider-man film one of them was
supposed to be the vulture but they put
venom in instead but the coolest thing
about the animated series is that Hank
Azaria from The Simpsons he does a
billion voices on The Simpsons
he did Eddie Brock on that classic
animated series
oh come on
quest where you go
this is not the first time they tried to
make a venom film originally amazing
spider-man 2 was meant to set up a
spider-man Cinematic Universe at Sony
they were going to do sinister sakes
venom was one of the other movies that
they were getting ready to do
[Music]
leave us make progress I've identified
several worthy candidates now that
spider-man's gone this city will never
be the same oh I'm countin on that speak
in progress you're looking better
it comes and goes tell me more how many
men did you have in mind I want to keep
it small everything we need and already
at Oscorp access granted
no commuter here volunteer directly six
seven bradley serving a life sentence is
most eager to join us good
start with him but because of all the
financial trouble they have they had
that big hack that happened they decided
to make the deal with Marvel everything
went great with civil wars they have
their main franchise going on so all the
other stuff just got pushed to the
backburner but that doesn't mean that
they're not going to do all these other
films - so they're doing the animated
film with Miles Morales they'll still do
a sinister six movie eventually even
though a lot of those characters will
show up in the main film they'll still
be doing spin-off films in the way that
Deadpool is a spin-off film from the
x-men franchise so if you really like
the idea of rated-r venom stuff like
there's a really hardcore spider-man
film that doesn't have to be shackled to
the tone of the MCU film then thank
Deadpool and Logan for that because if
Deadpool didn't prove the model then
Logan just hammered home oh you can
totally make a rated R comic book film
people will go see it it will still make
billions and billions of dollars but you
all probably know a version of the venom
origin story so symbiote gets found in
outer space mysteriously brought to
earth it bonds with spider-man he gets
rid of it in at a very low point in his
life Eddie Brock just happens to be
nearby
the symbiote finds him in his perfect
match but not including that latest
Bendis guardians of the galaxy story
where they go to the planet the
descendants are from there have been
about nine hosts to the Venom symbiote
Eddie Brock and Flash Thompson are just
the biggest ones that people know about
back during Secret Wars Deadpool was
host to the symbiote we you guys can let
me know what is your favorite version of
the character and what do you want them
to do with this venom movie I think
whatever the story they go with they'll
have to tell a version of the origin
story so you'll have to incorporate some
spider-man but I think just to make it
easier for themselves they could just
have him already be venom when the movie
picks up and they can allude to
spider-man stuff throughout the movie I
do think it will be Eddie Brock but
that's mostly because Flash Thompson
already exists in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that's who this character is
right here he's much younger very
clearly it looks like they do not intend
to give him the symbiote anytime soon he
just meant to be a bully to Peter Parker
at at school so any venom that they do
will probably be the Eddie Brock version
of the character he can be an adult
it'll be a super hardcore and because I
was originally going to do an infinity
war spider-man video I'll just
push that by a couple days there's new
Star Wars they've been talking about a
Knights of Ren spin-off movie so I know
you guys love the idea of a dark side
force user movie so there's all kinds of
saga stuff that's happening I'll post
that later and obviously there's a bunch
of iron fists that just drop so be sure
to check that out I'll be posting Easter
eggs for the next couple of days what
you wait for that click here for new
guardians of the galaxy footage and
click here for that other spider-man
homecoming video thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight